[Music]
hey guys it's John from gspot I wanted
to make a quick video about net
convexity because we've been getting a
lot of questions about it so I'm just
going to start with uh options profile
go through the what we call the
convexity ladder um and that will take
us right towards net convexity just as a
reminder a lot of this information is
also in the resources tab under docs um
but we'll go through some things I guess
that that aren't that aren't in there
right
now um so the very beginning of net
convexity is the options profile the
options profile takes a volume traded so
far that day and classifies it as
customer sold or bought customer bought
is to the right and customer sold is to
the
left calls are in orange and puts are in
purple so we can see that we have a
stack of long calls at 5840 a stack of
customer short puts at 5735
uh a stack of customer long puts at
5820 um and a stack of short customer
short calls at
870 so for each of these options
positions on the ladder we can take the
gamma exposure of that particular
contract and aggregate it so um in the
case of these 5870 calls for instance we
know that they're customer short so that
means that it's um customer short gamma
but they're also pretty far out of the
money and being far out of the money
means that they don't have that much
gamma to them oh sorry so if we were to
then click on this gamma button we can
see oh there's basically nothing there
um that's because the gamma curve is
kind of shaped like a bell curve and it
is the strongest near the money and
intuitively that makes sense gamma is
supposed to tell us the rate of change
of the Delta of a contract with movement
in spot price we're not going to get too
deep into math but it's useful to know
that at the money options have the
highest gamma um that's intuitive
because if I'm buying a 50 Delta or an
at the money call or put I would expect
that um because it's right at the
juncture of being in versus out of the
money that as soon as it goes in the
money the Delta goes up a lot in
absolute value as soon as it goes out of
the money the Delta goes down a lot in
absolute value so um it's the most
sensitive so to speak to movements in
spot um so if we want to confirm that
intuition we can look at here there we
have um both customer long calls and
customer long puts there are more long
puts than long calls um so we should
expect that the uh 5835 strike is a
customer long gamma strike um and when
we click here we see that that is the
case and that the largest customer long
gamma strike is
5840 um which are these long calls up
here
now as you may have noticed the gamma
ladder or the convexity ladder doesn't
distinguish between puts and calls
because the gamma of a put and a call at
the same strike is actually the same um
it's just a way of understanding whether
customers are long or short options
weighted by their gamma uh at each
strike the reason that we might be
interested in something like that uh is
because it tells us whether um customers
are expecting an expansion in
volatility uh or a contraction right if
I'm buying options it's because I think
that there's going to be more movement
than whoever is pricing those options
thinks there will be um if I'm the the
easiest way to think about this is in
terms of buying both aut in a call um
the it's called The Long straddle the
long straddle is going to outperform if
there's more volatility uh than is
implied so what we could say by looking
at this profile is to say that customers
are long options between 5845 and 5820
because they expect um their long
volatility in this range and then their
short volatility um you know below 5815
it's kind of hard to see given given how
crazy this profile is today
um but but that's that's the concept
right where are people buying options
where they selling options and um we
want to understand that buying and
selling in terms of the sensitivity of
those options to changing their Delta
with movements and spot price because
that is what is going to need to be
hedged um on those options
so let me just actually jump to a
different ladder so you guys can see how
different one looks like this is spy
today um which is the opposite of SPX
and this will be helpful context for
understanding today's price action but
um spy is short short gamma basically
everywhere and so we would expect to see
sold calls and sold puts on the options
profile which is exactly what we see
right we see that there's this um
there's systematically selling out of
the money calls selling out of the money
puts and we also see that the gamma
profile is privileging the center of
that distribution um so that 582 is our
Max uh short gamma um typically when we
see something like this when we're
seeing short gamma we're basically
seeing uh participants that um if they
are exposed to very large movements are
going to have to hedge because they're
short options whereas if we see a
profile with a lot of long gamma like we
see with an SPX um we're seeing that
participants are uh
relatively content with large moves they
want large moves and so they're not
going to react uh aggressively or have
to improvise uh when we get really large
ranges okay so given that we have that
understanding let's move over to net
convexity on SPX all net convexity is is
summing all the bars on this lad so it's
saying if we were to add
up um all of our classified over order
flow so far today weighted according to
its current gamma right currently
current
positions then are we um long or short
gamma um and that's our net convexity so
the reason that we call it net convexity
is because if net convexity is positive
like it is today on SPX um it means that
uh SPX Traders benefit from large moves
in the underlying uh if it's negative it
means that they do not benefit from
large moves in the underlying and we can
see that it is very positive today but
it's quite negative for
tomorrow so another way to formulate
that instead of saying whether they
benefit from large moves or not is just
to say that um if net convexity is very
negative it means that participants are
selling volatility I'm actually so happy
that this is happening right now because
it'll be quite helpful to expl
um how I how I read net convexity anyway
sorry to go back to what I was saying um
if net convexity is very negative it
means that um participants have been
selling a lot of options I like to think
about and explain option selling as
providing liquidity right because if
somebody sells a put they are saying hey
I'm happy to buy at this price somebody
sells a call they're saying hey I'm
happy to sell at this price it means
that participants are uh providing a lot
of liquidity to the market which
actually stifles stifles movement gets
us those scenarios which are more likely
to be putting a floor underneath the
market and giving us sort of a gentle
grind up that type of thing whereas if
we have participants that are really
long um that are really long volatility
or long options sorry I use some of
these terms interchangeably um because
they are more or less interchangeable um
but if we see positive net convexity
what that's telling us is hey people are
buying a lot of options because they
expect a lot of movement and they don't
want to be taking a lot of risk in this
market so in some ways you could
actually think about um net convexity as
your sort of zero DTE vix or in the case
of next um on SPX one DTE vix um except
it's a little bit more advanced than
that so to speak so for instance um with
net convexity Rising all day today on
SPX I'm actually concerned and that's
why I was saying I wasn't surprised that
we got this massive move here um and I
understand massive from the perspective
Ive of okay well you know it was only
seven points but how quickly it happened
because I'm basically saying with okay
net convexity is positive there's not
that much liquidity out there today
relative to other days um so I not
surprised to see that we get these sorts
of big whippy moves in terms of why
today's price action has been a little
bit more stifled um I mean we opened the
day up around half a percent um on SPX
due to some news concerns that over the
weekend that didn't end up
manifesting and um but net convexity was
Rising as of 10:30 in the morning so on
SPX which is um from the perspective of
notional value the most important ticker
so seeing that I would say okay well I'm
not really interested I don't think that
they we're going to get a trend day
typically when we get up Trend days on
SPX they're marked by volatility selling
as participants by futures or other
underlyings along with their option
selling so when I see that participants
are buying
today um that net convexity is positive
uh I was thinking out of the gate okay
um it's unlikely that we're going to
continue to move up it's interesting
though that we're getting so much
volatility selling for tomorrow um so
that's actually giving me a scenario in
which well we're not very likely to move
up like crazy today but also we do have
a little bit of a floor underneath us
and another thing that could hint that
that's the case is if we take a look at
spy as we would
expect um net convexity on spy is
negative and has been trending negative
all day meaning that spy participants
usually I I would associate them with uh
smaller time Traders like more retail
traders that sort of thing so sometimes
they get it wrong but in general they
have been selling volatility all day and
um if we look at the current value of
net convexity it's around uhga -2000 uh
this is in um Millions per percent move
because it's just the aggregation of the
ladder um and so then if we were to
compare that with SPX
um we'll see that it's not irrelevant
right SPX is around 3.7 positive so the
fact that SX for tomorrow is mostly
selling volatility um and we have a
negative value of 1.6 and then we have
spy at around -2 uh now again this is in
thousands of millions so billions um is
sort of telling me that I'm getting a
bit of a mixed picture as far as net
convexity is concerned today um now spy
has a tendency to trade a little bit
more directional so um like a very
bullish setup on spy would be actually
positive net convexity positive
aggregate decks that'll be a different
video um but spy participants have more
of a tendency to buy options than SPX
participants do um so that's why I'm
saying that when net convexity is
positive on SPX that tells me hm
something is a little bit weird here um
we're likely to get either choppy price
action or a move down the one the one
exception to that would be days of event
volatility like fomc days things like
that there we tend to see that SPX has
positive net convexity and you have to
rely on other things to um figure out
what direction we're likely to go um
because in general Traders tend to
purchase options on those days
understandably hey just a quick note
from the editor here if we are going
into an event and net convexity is very
very positive and we don't end up
selling off after the event then all of
those options that got bought all of
that lifting of implied volatility all
of that has to now come out of the
market and so that's actually potential
energy that will be able to fuel us to
the upside so a lot of times if we see
really um positive readings in net
convexity it's telling us it's giving us
a warning sign but at the same time and
markets seem to have a tendency to work
this way if nothing happens all of that
is part of our wall of worry or it's or
fueled for the upside so just another
thing to keep in mind and we have other
metrics that um work in tandem with this
to help a little bit more in these
instances um but I just wanted to
mention that in addition I mean this is
very specific right it's we we have an
event net convexity is really positive
and we're holding in the 15 minutes half
hour after the event something like that
hopefully this makes sense it's a
relatively um how would I put it like
these concepts are relatively simple
it's just that they're they build on a
lot of understanding right so you need
to know what an option is you need to
know what gamma is then you need to
understand that we're classifying volume
intraday and then seeing the gamma
exposure of that classified volume um
and then you need to understand that we
are uh aggregating or or rather sorry
summing the state of the ladder to get
this metric and that's actually how all
of our net metrics work um and so I
personally use net convexity on SPX as
my gauge of risk um so today was telling
me actually okay this is there's a
little bit of risk today um and usually
I'll combine SPX and spy um in order to
do that I'll take spy with a grain of
salt I'll keep in mind the relative
magnitude uh of the one to the other um
but yeah I mean if net convexity stays
up here in positive like I will likely
be fading the top of this range um it's
really interesting because 5835 has been
a really big level all day it's our
major negative um on the gex profile
which is for another video but um you've
seen every time we come up into 35 it's
worth a fade um and um that's more or
less what I've been doing all day since
netx city has been positive again I
haven't been expecting that the floor is
going to fall out from under us because
of some of the things that I'm seeing
elsewhere um but it does give me some
very useful context to understand okay
um there is not as much liquidity today
as uh on other days well that's
everything for this video I hope that
you guys have enjoyed it uh good luck
out there trading and I'll be back soon
with another one thanks for using X
[Music]